tropical storm Gordon is now blamed for
at least one death Gordon made landfall
in Dauphin Island Alabama last night
before hitting the mainland just west of
the Alabama Mississippi border a child
was killed in Pensacola Florida after
the limb of an oak tree crashed down on
a mobile home
Manuel Bojorquez is outside that home in
Pensacola and well good morning good
morning you can see behind me where this
tree sliced through the family's home
just as tropical storm Gordon was coming
ashore here along the Florida Panhandle
this morning here in Pensacola we still
had heavy bands of rain moving through
and even though the storm did not reach
hurricane status it still caused all
kinds of problems along the Gulf Coast
overnight tropical storm Gordon lashed
the Gulf Coast bringing driving rain and
powerful winds of 70 miles an hour to
three states the brunt of the storm
slammed Dauphin Island Alabama were
forceful Gus toppled trees flooded
buildings ripped apart billboards and
sent large waves crashing along the
shore better get around this quickly or
it gets in worse
earlier on the island home to fewer than
1300 people a strong storm surge flooded
streets leaving roads impassable
flooding remains the biggest threat for
millions of Americans as the storm moves
inland up to a foot of rain is expected
in some areas and that could produce
flash flooding for some the damage is
done this boat nearly collapsed due to
violent wind gusts and here in Pensacola
a young child was killed when a large
limb from an oak tree fell on this
mobile home crews there worked through
the night and after a few hours were
able to recover the body the storm will
weakened to a tropical depression today
but that does not mean that the threat
of additional damage or flooding is over
in fact as it moves north the threat of
isolated tornadoes remains Gayle all
right Thank You Manuel